alors les sondages commandés publié en
pleine campagne présidentielle sont ils
de trop quel impact peuvent avoir ses
intentions de vote faut-il s'en passer
on attend vos réactions sur le conte
télégramme verte et français l'ont déjà
été nombreuses à notre face à face s'est
tout de suite
[Musique]
et avec nous pourrons parler denis
demonpion éditorialiste politique
bonsoir denis demonpion merci d'être
avec nous sur ce plateau à vos côtés
thomas vos skis et membre du collectif
droite pour la france vous vous
présentez comme la droite qui n'est pas
macro compatibles c'est important de le
préciser bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous alors ne plus commander ni commenté
d'ailleurs des sondages c'est une
décision qui fait évidemment beaucoup
parlé réagir aux téléspectateurs seront
le comte télégramme daté france on
commence par regarder l'un des messages
un jean ou qui nous écrit tout
simplement ça c'est en une phrase il
oriente surtout les gens indécis voici
pour le premier commentaire du soir
denis demonpion des sondages qui
servirait à rien qui orienterait en plus
les légendes et si c'est juste à ça que
ça sert les sondages mais les sondages
se fait partie du jeu mais je ne pense
pas que fait un effet réel au moment du
vote puisque beaucoup de gens se
détermine une fois dans l'isoloir
souvent donc qu'une des sondages sont
plus fait pour les médias en réalité
faire parler les journalistes évidemment
qui en joue pourquoi parce que les
candidats n'ont pas tous les jours une
chose nouvelle à annoncer même si c'est
un peu la grande braderie en ce moment à
six mois des élections et donc voilà il
commande des sondages d'ailleurs un des
experts en la matière ça a été nicolas
sarkozy donc c'est présente quand il
était président de la république pour un
oui pour un non
il demandait un sondage pour indexer un
peu son comportement
y compris d'ailleurs
pour ces affaires de coeur un puisqu'on
se souvient que après le départ de
cécilia il avait commandé des sondages
pour voir si les français jugeraient
d'un bon oeil
qu'il se remarie alors qu'il était à
l'elysée enfin moyer c'est ils se font
plus plaisir au fond les hommes
politiques avec ces sondages qu'autre
chose mais ce qui est intéressant dans
le cas de ouest france c'est que il faut
le rappeler c'est quand même le
quotidien qui a le plus gros tirage en
france tous les jours et ce n'est pas
rien qu'un journal comme celui ci décide
à six mois des élections de faire
l'impasse totale sur la fabrique de
l'information d'une certaine manière on
va en parler justement sur ses
conséquences avec vous parce
qu'évidemment c'est extrêmement
intéressant
tommaso vos skis sur cette décision de
ouest france et sur l'utilité des
sondages vous allez regretter je vous
allez arrêter de lire ouest-france parce
que ça va être moins intéressants ou au
contraire vous trouvez que c'est une
décision avec beaucoup de panache
finalement il fallait avoir le courage
de la prendre et elle est fort utile
alors je dirais que dans cette dans
cette campagne il ya un peu la
jurisprudence zemmour sur un peu tout
donc c'est assez intéressant sérier les
juristes ans et moore sur le csa il y
avait là claude zemmour pour la primaire
des républicains alors maintenant ouest
france parce que c'est zemmour parce
qu'il faut quand même un très honnête
dit ah bah non ça pourrait des zemmour
le grand fasciste donc on va arrêter les
sondages dont je trouve qu'ils sont pas
très à leur place là dessus pour
évidemment trouver de manière un peu
tortueuses un truc mais finalement non
après pour votre question de tout à
l'heure et cela me permette de répondre
oui et les sondages on peuvent avoir un
effet mais non il ne crée pas les
candidats ou via
le sondage on parle juste des sondages
d'intentions de vote parce qu'après il
ya plein de sondage qui peuvent être
faits sur l'opinion etc mais
effectivement il peut arriver à un
moment que lorsque vous devez déterminer
votre choix vous avez notamment dans une
présidentielle ou dans l'autre sa
constance envie de voter pour un
candidat qui peut accéder au second tour
donc pour le vote utile effectivement je
dis bah alors si j'ai un candidat qui a
3 % et l'autre qui peut-être peut se
qualifier je pète plutôt voter pour
celui là donc ça peut avoir
effectivement un effet sauf qu'on en est
pas là et aujourd'hui de toute façon
quand on dit que les sondages vont si
vous voulez inventer des choses là où s
france ils sont quand même un petit peu
de mauvaise foi je dirais là dessus
c'est que c'est pas les sondages qui
font vendre le livre d'eric zemmour
c'est pas les sondages qui remplissent
les salles et c'est donc après sur un
autre sujet si ouest france veut dire il
n'ya pas que les sondages et il ya des
débats de fond je suis d'accord mais
dans ce cas là j'ai envie de renvoyer la
balle à l'ensemble des médias c'est à
dire que moi je suis à fond pour du
débat les arguments et ce soit ça qui
convainque les personnes bas il n'y a
pas que ouest france en l'occurrence que
couvre la compagne avant mais pour
n'importe quelle élection on voit quand
même qu'il ya des grands débats qui sont
organisées le soir du premier tour moi
je rêve d'un pays où ce soit avant le
premier tour td grande soirée électorale
donc ouest france n'est pas leur faute
donc si ils se servent de ça pour faire
vraiment débat de fond sur les
propositions très bien donc on va les
juger
sinon ce qu'ils vont faire des nuls de
mon option évidemment cette question
zemmour faux procès de la part de thomas
sophos qui sait voilà c'est parce qu'il
ya cette ce spectre zemmour qui ne plaît
pas
le spectre et moore pour qui il se
trouve qu eric zemmour
s'est pas lancé en campagne mais a
commencé à comme on dirige un exposé ses
points de vue ce qui pourrait être un
programme pour le lancement de son livre
la france n'a pas dit son dernier mot
alors je rappelle quand même que il est
fréquent pour les hommes politiques de
faire un livre ça a été le cas d'arnaud
montebourg ça a été le cas de nombreux
valérie pécresse pour voir les pianos
jacques chirac à l'époque que jacques
chirac tous l'ont fait dès délivre un
peu programmatique emmanuel macron demi
mène avec révolution c'était
avant même qu'il ne se déclare avait
publié ce livre il se trouve qu eric
zemmour est un peu singulier dans le
paysage pourquoi parce que son précédent
livre le suicide français avait eu déjà
une audience extraordinaire puisque il
avait vendu plus de 500000 exemplaires
ce qui n'est pas rien quand on sait
qu'un livre en moyenne savant 10000
quinze mille copies
quand françois hollande arrivent à 60
milles c'est presqu'un record oui
c'est quand même voilà ça dit quelque
chose il remet ça aujourd'hui parce que
en eut fait avec le suicide français il
était apparu pour un déclinistes vais à
la mode il n'était pas le premier
d'ailleurs à
tabler sur le déclin de la france est
aujourd'hui ces voix là on se retrousse
les manches on se ressaisit et il
distille un petit peu ce que contient
son livre d'une certaine manière alors
la question évidemment ce qui était un
secret de polichinelle sera utile ou pas
candidat évidemment qu'il le sera
aujourd'hui c'est une question lui même
le dit d'ailleurs ou son entourage c'est
une question de date il est
vraisemblable que ce sera au tour du du
15 novembre
certains mêmes disent que ça pourrait
être le 11 novembre
est donc
alors que eric zemmour
décoiffe c'est certain pourquoi parce
que il ya
les sondages ont beaucoup joué sur cette
rivalité je soupçonne la droite pourquoi
sonder les candidats pas encore déclaré
je vous invite à regarder encore cette
réaction celle de david à
ça inspire de téléspectateurs cette
question des sondages parce qu'il a
toujours sous jacent cette question des
manipulations les sondages ne sont pas
neutres vous n'avez qu'à répondre à l'un
d'eux et vous comprendrez comment s'est
orientée tous les candidats potentiels
ne sont pas pris en compte et des
questions sont verrouillées et orientez
vous êtes d'accord avec ce diagnostic
c'est vrai que tous les candidats ne
sont pas forcément sondés donc il ya une
manipulation là en dessous c'est pas
parce que c'est un argument qui revient
extrêmement souvent on l'a vu cet après
midi dans des messages un sérieux c'est
pas parce qu'un sondage est perfectible
et qui peut nous être adressée il ya
plein de problèmes avec les sondages
c'est pas pour ça que c'est une
manipulation info est un petit peu moi
ce que je trouve ça boureux sur les
sondages c'est quand même finalement les
républicains qui se prennent leur
boomerang dans la tête dont je fais
partie mais j'ai aussi fait partie de
ceux qui disaient il ne faut pas
s'appuyer sur les sondages pour désigner
notre candidat c'était comme la méthode
jacob
et il faut faire une primaire ouverte y
compris à ceux qui pourraient se
présenter y compris eric zemmour denis
payre ou qui siègent donc ils ont tenté
parce qu'en fait il voulait imposer à
son de candidats notamment vous avez
bertrand dire ouais faut que ce soit le
plus mieux placé dans les sondages c'est
quand même inédit dans l'histoire de la
vème république un parti disent devoir
garder les sondages pour choisir notre
candidat alors qu'il suffit de faire
voter les personnes m'ont finalement il
ya un congrès donc maintenant il se
retrouve dans un boomerang parce que ces
réexamens moore qui est en tête des
sondages pour effectivement là ils sont
un petit peu mal à l'aise mais c'est un
peu leur faute mais donc les sondages
pour moi ne mène plus rien les candidats
s'en servent en axe de communication et
chacun s'en sert seymour s'en sert pour
dire ce second tour bertrand dit c'est
moi qui peut gagner après les électeurs
j'ai envie de dire pour moi comme je
l'aï dit au début à part dans la
dernière ligne droite pour voter pour un
vote utile mais les déjà les intentions
de vote il ya une partie des gens qui
ceux qui sont dans les eaux loir qui
décide dans l'isoloir vdo tous ont déjà
décidé avant il peut y avoir un petit
effet mais vous ferez jamais passé une
personne qui a 2 % de votes entre
guillemets réel leurs sondages à 25%
c'est pas vrai ça joue à la marche en
tout cas le rédacteur en chef de ouest
france a écrit dans sa tribune qu'il ne
veut pas alimenter les débats
médiatiques il va même plus loin un
lecteur l'a interpellé sur twitter
regarder ce qu'il répond à françois
xavier
je n'ai pas parlé de complot mais de
manipulation ce qui n'est pas la même
chose ce n'est pas les sondeurs que je
mets en cause ce sont des gens sérieux
mais la manipulation des sondages
commenté tordu martelé est repris en
boucle sans aucun recul et c'est grave
françois-xavier le franc c'est vrai que
les grandes chaînes de télé par beaucoup
d'eric zemmour regardez encore si vous
regardez les chaînes info ce matin débat
sur le permis à points oui mais vous il
faut pas se tromper parce que il se
trouve que eric zemmour
a une popularité et ont peut-être contre
pour contre eric zemmour mais les faits
sont là et ces candidats sortis de nulle
part vous savez ça renvoie un peu à
coluche déjà quand coluche c'était
n'ont pas présenté mais avait laissé
entendre qu'il pourrait être candidat il
y avait eu tout de suite dé son âge et
il était arrivé à 11 12 13 % de
popularité des gens qui vraiment dès
demain était prête à voter pour lui eric
zemmour il se trouve que quand il a fait
son débat avec jean luc mélenchon il a
quand même ramassé un score
extraordinaire de près de 4 millions de
téléspectateurs alors que sur une autre
chaîne
darmanin mini intérieure ont tout de
suite plafonné à 1 est mignon ça dit
quelque chose d'un phénomène et il faut
pas perdre de vue que ce soit les
chaînes des télévisions ou les journaux
ils les ont quand même un intérêt c'est
de vendre
certains leurs pages de publicité et les
journaux du papier moi j'ai le souvenir
qu'en 2007 quand il a vu vous savez le
lancement de la campagne ségolène royal
nicolas sarkozy bons à cinq six mois il
était au coût d'un coup tout à coup il
ya un sondage qui faisait passer l'une
devant l'autre et puis après nicolas
sarkozy a pris le leadership bon et deux
de crainte que les commet rej acheteurs
de journaux ou télé spectateurs
s'ennuient
ils ont lancé ils étaient quelques-uns à
un vrai pour le troisième homme qui a
été françois balland et françois bayrou
a fait la une de tous les journaux il a
été invité dans toutes les émissions etc
etc et finalement
les électeurs se sont pris au jeu et
puisque dans les sondages il arrivait
quand même à 17% il a fait d'ailleurs un
très très bon score mais donc le pouvoir
quand même dès maintenant mais le cas de
deux noms pourquoi parce que françois
bayrou quand il est arrivé il avait
aussi un programme
très clair et c'est très important ça
quand ouest-france dit nous on va plus
traité de jumelage il faut espérer
qu'ils vont en effet faire un travail de
journaliste c'est à dire se
pencher sur le programme des candidats
ce que ça peut changer ou apporter comme
bien-être aux français ou pas c'est ça
les questions qui se posent leur est
parfois c'est du vent et d'ailleurs on
sait que des sondages se sont beaucoup
de tromper on l'a vu en 94 avec balladur
ou systématique
dessus justement la voyez vous faites là
bon date arrogance je veux dire la
transition la relation parce que c'est
aussi un débat si vous voulez les
sondages ça fait partie de la météo ça
fait chacun rebondi dessus que je veux
dire il ya eu des sondés s'en tenir au
mandat
je trouve toujours donc de toutes façons
un nom de 2,2 oui la météo à plus de 4
jours ça donc on
est donc une action plus de six mois est
de dire jacques chirac il était très bas
dans les sondages et il a continué il a
fait son livre est il arrivé il arrivait
deuxième tour donc c'est des personnes
qui sont derrière pas ça veut pas dire
que en juillet 94 ce sondage était faux
les choses ont changé donc c'est un
instantané les gens jouent avec voilà
effectivement - ouest-france si ils font
du contenu des choses très intéressantes
ce serait bien et j'espère qu'ils se
contenteront pas de crier au fascisme
dans la politique ce sont quand même
bizarre tromper mais on al'impression on
a comme l'impression que comme le
thermomètre affiche pas la bonne
température tout d'un coup on a envie de
le casser c'est à dire que pour d'autres
élections ils ont attendu que ce soit là
dessus et je pense qu'en plus c'est
complètement vain que sondages ou pas il
ya il ya et non des mots ils rataient
d'autres on va voir ce qui va se passer
dans la campagne aujourd'hui on zemmour
et la tuque à ce thermomètre ou pas et
ouest-france bas c'est très bien si il
alimenta campagne sur les vraies
attentes des français permis de conduire
en sécurité ou autres 1,1 dernier qui
est un petit message pour la route on
arrive à la fin de ce débat les sondages
existe t'il uniquement pour influencer
les canard sans tête qui se cherche un
sauveur évidemment qu'elle sondages sont
bidon nous dit sophie macro avec ses 3 %
les jeunes allaient 25 pensant aux
présidentielles lol construite elle
n'est ni démentir mais c'est vrai que
c'est assez paradoxal parce que on
crédite
emmanuel macron d'un score phénoménal
bon attention devos 25% mais sa
popularité serait supérieure à 40% bon
déjà il faut regarder quel média mairie
sollicite ces sondages c'est très
important parce que c'est ce que disait
un quart d'heure de la proximité
de ces instituts de sondage et de ces
médias avec le président de la
république et ce qui est quand même
curieux si on regarde les résultats
c'est que malgré cette
soi-disant popularité et bien emmanuel
macron et son parti n'ont pas réussi à
faire de percer ni aux municipales ni
aux régionales donc ça pose un problème
quand même il ya quand même là une
espèce de faux celle entre les deux
alors c'est vrai que l'élection
présidentielle c'est d'un autre type
puisque c'est la rencontre entre un ou
une candidate candidats candidates et
les électeurs donc c'est un un autre jeu
mais il faut quand même
rappeler que
l'abstention est très importante en
france y compris à l'élection
présidentielle à la dernière élection
qui a vu emmanuel macron
élus et bien il y avait quand même
autant d'abstentionnistes et deux
bulletins blancs quand on a eu marine le
pen ce qui en dit long sur le malaise
dans ce pays merci en tout cas à tous
les deux tommaso vos skis denis à deux
mentions un signal à la sortie de votre
nouvel hommage politiques dr denis
demonpion docteur la mort le légiste qui
a autopsié et linate dit cette histoire
inédite chez robert laffont merci à vous
deux d'avoir été en direct avec nous